today marks the beginning of what
millions of Americans and all major
corporations consider to be the single
holiest month of the entire year it is
pride month of course and as you've
probably noticed the observances are
well underway uh maybe you've seen a
bunch of Pride Flags everywhere maybe
you've noticed all of the pride themed
advertisements maybe there's a pride
parade marching down your street at this
very moment full of naked people
exposing themselves to Children if
you're in San Francisco that's a
year-round activity of course whatever
the case pride is here and for decades
you know it used to be that Pride was
just one day sort of like a transgender
day of remembrance or the intersex
awareness day or pansexual Pride day
international pronouns day but now pride
is four weeks long can't avoid it if you
try it's the literal celebration of one
of the seven deadly sins and it simply
can't be ignored it's all encompassing
so last year on June 1st we decided to
um you know join in and mark the
occasion my documentary what is a woman
premiered at the daily you are one year
ago today to start off pride month it
was a very deliberate Choice by us to
start the month with this film for the
film my team and I as you know traveled
all over the world asking that simple
question in the title just a few years
ago and throughout all of human history
before that the question would not have
stumped a single person if we had made a
film called what is a woman in the year
2010 and gone around asking this
question everybody would be very
confused but confused for a different
reason confused about why we're asking
such an obvious question to begin with
but we found that in 2022 it was a real
mind twister
to be sure some people you know had no
problem telling us what a woman is the
tribes men we met in Kenya could answer
the question easily for example so could
the Vietnam veteran in Washington state
who runs his own store selling Star Wars
memorabilia but we found that the kind
of people who celebrate pride month the
identity obsessed members of Congress
the gender studies professors the
Physicians who make a lot of money
mutilating children and so on they could
not give us an answer
in fact
they couldn't give us anything
resembling an answer they couldn't get
close to an answer they just started
dissembling and in many cases they ran
away or they screamed at us or both
these are the activists the medical
experts who will tell you without
hesitation that trans women are women
they'll have you fired from your job
ostracized for the rest of your life if
you disagree with them
but they can't even Define the word what
is a woman was an international success
because most people recognize how absurd
this is I mean don't we have free speech
in this country isn't this what the
country was founded on isn't it the
basis for the First Amendment to our
constitution what's the point of all
that exactly if it can't protect us when
we speak openly and honestly about
whatever we want to talk about and in
particular what's the point of all of
that if we can't even ask a question
about the most fundamental and immutable
aspect of our identity
something that's embedded at the
chromosomal level which is our sex
this is Way Beyond free speech
okay this is an attack not just on
speech but on the ability to speak
basic fundamental truth
in a country where speaking the truth
not your truth but the truth has somehow
become a revolutionary act it makes
sense that what is a woman became a
revolutionary film and one of the most
influential and more one of the most
talked about documentaries of the
century we've screened the film all over
the country every time we've gotten a
massive response we've shown it at
colleges that don't allow dissent on
this issue in the classroom
and since the release of the film we've
done even more to expose the damage
that's being done by activists who deny
the reality of biology including at
Vanderbilt Medical Center where they
abuse children for profit of course
we've seen laws being passed all across
the country and the film we're proud to
say was a catalyst for a lot of that
helped to be a catalyst for a lot of
that but the the incredible positive
response to the film was met with Fury
and rage on the other side the film has
been banned from major big Tech
platforms denounced as hate speech
reviled by many of the worst people in
our country it also made me personally
Public Enemy Number One to many of these
trans activists a title that I'm proud
to still hold and one that I intend to
keep for as long as I live
I am very much proud to be hated by
these kinds of people
I don't mind the hatred
what I do mind is the censorship the
fear
the refusal to even engage
and that's why we've been excited to see
the changes to Twitter this past year
Under New Management for the first time
the owner of a major social media
platform didn't just promise to respect
the freedom of speech of all the users
he seemed to really mean it Elon Musk
lifted the previous regime's political
bans on thousands of users including the
former president United States uh musk
also it seemed eliminated it seemed
eliminated Twitter's rules which
required that you respect the fake
pronouns and gender identities of other
users
and musk promise transparency in
Twitter's algorithm so that people with
unfavorable opinions wouldn't be Shadow
banned anymore they wouldn't be
suppressed
and it was for all those reasons this
year that we reached out to Twitter
about Distributing what is a woman on
their platform for free you know for all
users
this is how we plan to Mark the one year
anniversary of the film and it's how we
wanted to ring in pride month 2023 we
wanted to take the movie that LGBT
cultists hate the most and put it out in
its entirety for free on one of the most
traffic social media platforms on the
planet and we wanted to do it on the
first day of pride month
that was the plan
now as the daily wire CEO Jeremy boring
wrote earlier today uh Twitter was
initially receptive to this idea in fact
they were excited about it they pledged
to set up a custom landing page just for
the film so that everybody could find it
easily this is something that we were
happy to pay for this is a privilege
that we were going to pay Twitter for uh
Twitter signed an agreement to that
effect
then after all that they asked to review
the film because they wanted to screen
it for any content that might quote
trigger users on its platform because
they wanted to know you know how they
were going to respond if when the when
the film proved to be controversial now
that was a giant red flag obviously
since when do Free Speech platforms talk
about trigger warnings to begin with
and indeed after reviewing the film uh
as you might have seen Twitter suddenly
changed its mind switched course
instead of promising to promote the film
Twitter informed us that they would
dramatically restrict its reach
they labeled it as a hateful content
and they were going to make it as hard
as possible to find without outright
Banning it
so all the shadow bands that we heard
about in the past under the old regime
and we were told the shadow bands were
gone we're now being told by Twitter
that they will do that to this film when
we post it because it is hate speech
they said
they would ensure that it would not
appear in people's feeds the algorithm
would crush it completely we were told
by Twitter that that is what they're
going to do
now how could that be we asked what what
hateful content were they talking about
exactly what where's what's the the
hateful part of the film I mean I made
the movie I'm in it I don't remember any
hateful content
Twitter directed us to two clips in
particular from what is a woman uh that
they said
are hateful content and because of these
segments of the film it becomes hate
speech and they're going to restrict its
reach on the platform
now I'm going to show you both of these
clips because it's hard to believe that
they're really saying it's hard to
believe anyway if you took their new
commitment to free speech seriously if
you took that seriously then uh this
will be shocking to you
in the first clip a father in Canada
tells us that he was arrested and he was
fine thirty thousand dollars his crime
was referring to his 14 year old
daughter as a she the father tried to
prevent doctors from pumping his
daughter full of hormones
and tried to protect his daughter from
mutilation and um and uh and Butchery so
the Canadian government destroyed his
life
and now Twitter is calling this father
hateful and they're saying that you
shouldn't hear what he has to say
because of this clip which we will play
right now listen
hello hey is this this is yes hey it's
it's Matt Walsh are you where are you
right now
I'm a Vancouver British Columbia Canada
right now are you can are you able to
leave
I'm not able to leave BC I can't even go
to another province in Canada right now
uh and it's because I'm technically out
on bail
what happened exactly
[Music]
thank you
how exactly did did this get into the
courts to begin with right so what
happened is we set up a meeting with BC
Children's Hospital and according to the
BC Children's Hospital website there's
going to be a thorough evaluation and
I'm thinking good this is going to be
the end of it all they're going to
clearly see that my child is not the
opposite sex so my ex-wife brings my
child into BC Children's Hospital I get
a call less than an hour into that
appointment is that they were going to
pump or full of cross-sex hormones
within the hour and I put a halt to that
I said no
they agreed to stop for the moment they
figured well let's get the dad on board
too this is all going to be better let's
just get everybody on the same page I
said it's not going to happen so I get a
letter from BC Children's Hospital in
December of 2018 and it says that under
the BC infants act they will start
injecting my child with cross-sex
hormones and I have two weeks to respond
with legal action if I so choose and so
that's how I ended up in court because I
did respond with legal action so you
called your daughter
a she and you you went to jail for that
it's considered criminal violence to uh
not use the preferred pronouns it is no
different than let's say I were to take
a broomstick and whack one of my kids
over the head so they were treating it
in a similar fashion that misgendering
mispronouncing my child was the
equivalent of Family Violence is she on
the hormone pills now
[Music]
she is the court ordered that she could
do whatever she wanted
now what happened to The Man In that
clip is becoming common in Canada
fathers are now often required in a
supposedly free country to stay quiet as
doctors castrate their children
and that's exactly what these off-label
hormones do they sterilize girls and
women
um they cause all kinds of other
problems too including early onset
osteoporosis we spoke to one person in
the documentary who experienced some
truly horrible uh symptoms but according
to to the court system in Canada fathers
have no right to protect their daughters
from any of that
they want to shut those parents up
and now apparently Twitter agrees with
the courts in Canada
by the way
um that father has a sentencing hearing
this week and may be on his way back to
jail
back to jail in a case that began with
him simply wanting to raise his daughter
as his daughter and refer to her as such
began with a father not wanting his
daughter to be sterilized
takes a special kind of company to want
to partner with my show I say a lot of
things that make a lot of people angry
and this tends to scare off advertisers
that's uh just part of the bargain
that's why I'm so grateful for partners
like pure talk who stand behind me and
my show no matter the consequences they
might face that takes real courage in
their part it really does pure talk
shares my values which is why we've made
them the official cell phone wireless
partner of the daily wire that's not the
only reason though Pure Talk offers the
most Dependable 5G Network in the US I
use it myself it's a great product so
you're not just buying it because you're
supporting the cause you're buying that
but also it's a great product and a
great service their plan their plans are
top tier but at a fraction of the cost
of ATT Verizon or T-Mobile you can get
unlimited text talk and unlimited data
with a mobile hotspot for just 55 a
month you vote with how you spend your
money so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you instead
go to puretalk.com Welsh they'll get
great coverage and you'll save while
you're doing it when you go to
puretalk.com Walsh you'll save an
additional 50 off your first month
because they act really value you if you
can imagine that that's puretalk.com
Walsh Pure Talk Wireless for Americans
buy Americans
so I want you to think about what
Twitter is doing here
they're not even accusing me of hate
speech right they're actually accusing
this father a man who's already been
arrested tried jailed had his life
destroyed they're accusing him of
committing hate speech against his own
daughter simply because he acknowledges
that she is a girl
now that was one clip there's another
clip that Twitter objected to as well uh
this clip features the aforementioned
shop owner and Vietnam War veteran who
used biologically accurate pronouns in
response to a trans activist who was
accosting him in his store and here's
what that hateful content looks like
[Music]
how long have you been running the shop
here 25 years wow now you had an
incident here a little while ago that
went really viral online uh lots of
reaction in the public Aberdeen
councilwoman T.S semestis confronted
owner Don suker about a sign he posted
in his store one day I just put the sign
up over here and uh he came around the
corner and I thought okay I recognize
him I said oh I recognize you you're our
new city councilman he says no I'm your
new city council woman so it was It was
kind of on from there you know what
no what you're spouting no it's not
trans women are women sir that sign is
I've been doing this 25 years I've never
had a problem with anybody whether
they're gay transsex anything now you're
saying councilman he
this individual was saying I'm a woman
right and you said you're not a woman
how do you know that that person is not
a woman how do I know yeah well uh
Common Sense
doesn't doesn't the science say that
if someone identifies as a woman then
they are no no now that's completely
bogus I don't care if you think you're a
sheepdog
and you come into my store it don't
matter to me just don't come in and try
to shove that down my throat if it makes
someone feel better what about their
their feelings I don't give a about
their feelings I'm old they're on a Star
Wars universe
Jar Jar Binks
pansexual do you think
transgender
um
why why that why would I even care if
it's his truth
well it ain't true you're not a
scientist you're not a gender Studies
major or are you no okay how do you know
that you're a man how do I know that I
met I guess because I got it
huh
well I guess Don isn't overthinking it
he admits he's not a gender Studies
major
for the very least a doctor
now not that this really matters but how
many Americans in this country do you
think agree with that store owner if he
ran a poll and said can men transform
into women in an instant what results do
you think you'd get now I asked a poll
that says can men become women that's
the question not a poll that asks do you
believe in gender affirming care
but most people have no idea what that
means
if you phrase it simply to people so
they understand the question
well what kind of results do you think
you get of course most people would
agree with the store owner the only
difference is that most Americans are
too afraid to be honest about it
because of exactly what happened to that
store owner
store owner was not honest it was was
not afraid to be honest so a mob of
activists tried to ruin his life
and now Twitter is once again trying to
silence him and I have to continue to
emphasize
what makes this so egregious is that
it's not simply speech okay it's not
that the Star Wars shop owner Don suker
it's not that they were that he was just
giving his opinion about something this
is not his opinion
it's bad enough to silence people who
are giving their opinions we should have
a society and we should have big Tech
platforms where you can have an opinion
you can have any opinion about anything
and you can voice that opinion if other
people don't like it they can voice
their opinions then you have a you have
a debate about it that's the way it's
supposed to work in a free Society but
my point is that this is not his opinion
this is just the truth
and so yes they're suppressing Free
Speech but more importantly they are
suppressing the truth
now we reached out to Twitter about
their objection to these clips we've had
we've had had extensive conversations
with them in fact
behind the scenes about this
um so that's the other thing you need to
know is that on Twitter's end this is
not some algorithmic glitch okay this is
a very intentional decision on their
part when they told us that they're
going to suppress it and label it hate
speech this was a decision that was made
we know that because we talk to them
and when we talked to them they said um
that it's uh that it that it's violates
their misgendering policy now we asked
them didn't Twitter remove its
misgendering policy because it was a
misnomer you know misgendering just
means you're correctly gendering someone
didn't they allow Twitter users to once
again refer to others with accurate
pronouns instead of inaccurate ones
they did take that language off of their
policy that happened recently but
Twitter told us that actually
misgendering is still considered abuse
and harassment on the platform uh and
they just they just don't specify it
anymore
so they asked us to edit our film to
comply with this new rule this new
unspoken rule against using accurate
pronouns and of course uh we refused
we're not going to do that I mean
obviously we're not going to do that
which means that the daily wire is still
going to distribute what is a woman
tonight
starting at 8 pm Eastern we're going to
make it available on Twitter for
everyone to see for free it's going to
stream tonight at 8 pm Eastern it'll be
available thereafter for 24 hours
whether Twitter Twitter will let you see
it or not that's what remains unclear
you know whether they actually tag it
with the hate speech label and suppress
it that's the part that we're going to
find out
this is a documentary that more than a
year after its release is still being
suppressed
I mean think about that a year later
and they're still suppressing it they
are still terrified of this movie they
do not want you to see it
the reason for that is obvious they know
that it's effective
they know that they can't answer even
the most basic questions about their
ideology
and that's the reason that sane people
uh aren't calling for you know bans on
trans activists by the way
we're we're not returning the favor
when Elon Musk took over Twitter we
weren't saying ban all the trans
activists we're not trying to kick them
off the platforms and silence them on
the contrary we want to debate them we
want them to speak we want them to be
able to speak we want and we want us to
be able to speak we want you to hear the
contrast
in fact that's one of the great ironies
of this whole thing Twitter's attempt to
suppress us all the other censorship
that we faced what makes it so ironic is
that for most of the film
we allow the trans activist side to
speak they're constantly complaining let
us speak let our voices be heard
and this movie is us saying okay here
you go
hey the stage is yours
let's hear your side
most of the movie consists of them
speaking we give them the floor
we give them the camera and the
microphone
because we want people to hear them
we want their ideology to be fully
exposed
and if that ideology is going to hang we
want it to hang itself and we want you
to see it hanging itself and it did
and that's the main reason why they hate
this movie so much
because we didn't go around arguing with
them and yelling at them
we just asked them questions and said
here you go tell us tell us all about
your your position
and they humiliated themselves
all the supposed experts the doctors all
these people that were told trust the
experts but we went to The Experts we
put cameras in front of their faces
and we said okay experts
give us your spiel
and they came off like idiots and
maniacs
that's not our fault
that's on them
if Twitter's ever going to be a free
speech platform which Elon Musk says he
badly wants it to be then um these
people cannot be allowed to suppress
speech
Twitter likes to throw out the freedom
of speech is not freedom of reach
argument but that's a cowardly Dodge
it's no different than IDI Amin's famous
quote there's freedom of speech he said
but I can't guarantee Freedom after
speech
now there's still time for Twitter to
reverse this decision if it wants to be
a free speech platform it must reverse
this decision this is a time for
choosing Twitter has to pick a side
everyone has to pick a side either you
are fully on the side of sanity and
freedom and common sense or you are
against it
you gotta choose it is one or the other
there's no middle ground
one or the other it's always been that
way
now as for us in the meantime no matter
what happens we are not going to
self-censor
and we are definitely not going to bow
to the sensors in Silicon Valley we hope
you'll watch the film tonight at 8pm
introduce it to as many people as you
can watch it share it make sure people
see it
and we hope you'll continue to check the
daily wire and its Twitter feeds and
everything we're doing throughout pride
month because we have a lot planned and
if Twitter's actions this week tell us
anything it's that this fight is if
anything even more important today than
it was a year ago
it also shows that we are winning we are
winning
and they are scared
and that's why they try to silence us
but we will not be silenced no matter
what hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code walls
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there